like bro the left lies it's what they do
they say we're just defending ourselves
as they throw bricks and firebombs at
people and how many times can you fall
for it first of all but also kind of
what you were saying about the whole
idea of protesting even if it's
peacefully about something a see away is
particularly I think it's harmful on a
level that they don't understand
obviously because they're removed from
it but also you're influencing what that
country kind of does in a way the same
way we were talking about Co with all
the and in the middle of that all the
George Floyd stuff it's like why is
London protesting someone that was
killed on our why why is the UK and
Paris like why and it's it's you don't
understand what's going on and that's
one of the things that's uncomfortable
on days like this where obviously you
know our job to talk about politics but
it's hard to really say what we want to
happen or what should happen and then
it's also even harder because they're so
comfortable saying what they want to
happen